do you guys remember the story about the
guy who went to the empire state
building and then like it was like a
revenge killing it was a disgruntled
employee no so he goes to the empire
state building he's all angry and then
he takes a handgun and he shoots a bunch
of people he leaves the building and the
nypd they run up to stop him and they
start firing wildly hitting like seven
oh yeah or something
when was this uh
three years ago i think i i totally
don't remember this it's kind of tragic
i think seven people got hit that's my
guess but
i'm guessing it's seven people other
than the guy there yeah they did 2012 uh
all empire state shooting victims were
wounded by officers according to the
police wow so uh on a busy friday
morning
let's pull this off let's let's jump
into the story
all right so this is this happened this
is cnn 2012 2012 okay what month uh
august
and so they say i was in i was in
training for gitmo back then so i missed
a couple all empire state shooting
victims were wounded by officers on a
busy friday morning in manhattan nine
pedestri nine pedestrians suffered
bullet or fragment wounds after police
unleashed a hail of gunfire at a man
walking with a 45-caliber pistol who had
just killed a former co-worker the
officers unloaded 16 rounds in the
shadow of the empire state building at a
disgruntled former apparel designer
killing him after he engaged in a gun
battle with police authorities said
three passerbys sustained direct gunshot
wounds while the remaining six were hit
by fragments according to the new york
police commissioner ray kelly all
injuries were caused by police all
injuries were caused by police one
officer shot nine rounds and another
shot seven please identified the gunman
as jeffrey johnson 58 who was apparently
laid off from his job as a designer of
women's accessories at hazaan import co
last year
johnson served in the us coast guard in
the mid 70s had two rounds left in his
pistol it holds eight kelly said
now i just want to point something out
what do you think would have happened if
those officers had rifles
ar-15s
i mean
you can never say right but if they're
going at range and this guy's moving if
he's you know if he's being furtive he's
if he's trying to you know use cover and
concealment
they would have had a better just just
talking based on the numbers they would
have had a better chance of hitting him
directly let's let's see let's not even
say a 556. let's say the police were
given a short barrel nine millimeter
with a stock
like come on man
you know i i understand we want we want
the cops to be arms uh armed these guys
well they would say militarization with
police right right right exactly that
would be there so they're saying the
cops we you know
a glock 17 or whatever and these cops
miss it's not an easy thing to do they
complain about police and police
brutality it's like okay then give them
a a short barreled rifle or ar pistol
with with us with a stock and they will
be
way more accurate they will they
one shot fired guys down stop stop the
murderer dead in his tracks as he
started shooting at cops less bullets
fired more accurate this is a good
example of like what you're saying that
that's exactly what i'm talking about
yeah it's it's not just the idea of
militarization of police it's the idea
of ar-15s are dangerous it's like dude
people who do with handguns like
handguns i'll admit i mean maybe it's
just me but rifle's way easier i go to
the range and i can hit everything with
the with the with the ar-15 well you've
got a longer term you've got a longer
barrel so and stabilizing it's more
stable it's it's more um
you know it's it's more forgiving
basically for those little mistakes with
you know four inch barrel on a handgun
right you got to be front sight focused
you got to be dead-on you have to have
your t all the way across
real quick what people don't understand
is that they assume an ar-15 is firing
five five six it's like you get get a
nine millimeter rifle yeah there are
different variants yeah or or 45
subsonic slower and
more accurate also i mean the vast
majority of gun violence is committed
well the vast majority of gun violence
is committed with handguns oh yeah all
rifles combined including the ar-15 kill
fewer people every year than hammers do
yeah oh i think sharks too incredibly
rare i don't know about sharks
yeah that's that's the thing and this is
what that judge actually in california
recently who struck down the um the
firearms ban the assault quote-unquote
assault weapons
yeah which it's funny because like i'll
go to like you know any uh any gun store
online you type in an assault weapon
like they won't tell you what they don't
tell you sell defense weapons it's weird
all day long
i walked into a store and i was like
hello sir i would like to buy one
assault weapon and the man said that's
not that one
weapon please one assault weapon one
weapon for assault they're like right
now what are you going through the words
the words you're saying don't right so
the judge the judge in this case and
that you know if you i haven't gone
through the whole thing it's this really
long uh opinion that he wrote that he
put down but the the uh the first part
of it which was driving you know sort of
like the anti-gun
types nuts he said it's called like a
swiss army knife and it says it's like a
swiss army knife because it's there when
you need it and it solves so many
different
uh different situations different
problems different challenges that arise
and the vast majority of this is like
this is the most popular gun in the
united states the vast majority of
people who use this uh never use it to
make to commit a crime they are lawful
they are law abiding they're using it
safely for lawful legal purposes this is
exactly what i've been trying to tell
people about my barrett m82 you know
like what happens if like i don't know
an international band of terrorists that
like exactly like the fast and furious
cure they're fighting and i see this
helicopter and i'm like look i gotta
protect my property from this
international cabal led by charlie's
throne and so i've got a 50 bmg you
never know
she's not going to be able to hit you
from the helicopter
i do love this though because like we
posted the vlog where i have the the
barrett i mean it's a 50 bmg and we were
shooting it at a play or whatever and
then these lefties are like what are you
going to hunt with that
and i was like what does hunting have to
do with anything yeah painting yeah
but for half a second i thought you said
plane it's like
you do wait
what are your plates just stealing
places
we were hoping that it would vaporize
the target
like it would because the steel plate
was rated for 308 and we're like if we
hit this it's probably gonna block we uh
uh one one one person dan got got got a
gr a glancing shot so it just dented it
but it was also on a wooden you know it
was mounted so it absorbed a lot of the
hit there's some places you can go where
where i've done and this is virginia
where they'll let you do like abandoned
cars
oh man like the glass in and everything
yeah we had like a bmw and a mercedes
and we were like take that one
i also got two at one point with one of
these things and they just buy these
junk cars for you to be able to use and
for tactical training um they had they
actually got
one of the trainings we went through was
firing a firing handgun from the
driver's seat through the windshield at
a target
so yeah so learning how the difference
so the angle of the windshield versus if
you know your target to okay your
target's here so you want to shoot
center mass but because of the angle of
deflection you actually want to kind of
fire down in a sense and it bends it up
so that it bends as though it hits the
glass and bends refraction and actually
crazy yeah reduction in action very good
and and people need yeah that's crazy it
was awesome it was it was it was just
amazing i always tell people behind the
engine block all right yeah
you know so you could do these tests
where they they'll they'll have the car
that was on the in the george floyd
square that was when when the shooting
broke out you can actually hear and i'm
guessing at some security who's there
with like it was like some british or
you know foreign um reporter and he like
doesn't know what to do and he hears
this guy just go get behind the engine
block go go go and that's yeah don't
don't hide behind the doors and don't
ever do that in the movies the cops are
literally behind the door and i'm like
dude that's like a millimeter of like
well steelers some some police cars will
have we'll have some warmer there but
yeah just just don't assume your car
isn't up or emerge you know if god
forbid you ever in this situation yeah
engine block all day long however i
don't know if you guys wanted to get
into this the engine block is also what
allows for pit maneuvers to take place
that oh that video that came out so it's
the same idea because yes the engine
block is this large chunk of metal right
that's right in the front of the car
but that's also what um leaves a car's
weight balance completely off right and
so your trunks never going to have more
weight than the engine block there's
this video that's going viral where a
cop is trying to pull over this woman
for some like minor traffic violations
and he decides you're speeding i think
she's speeding so he decides to murder
her did you straight up kill the woman
what so i'm i'm being a bit hyperbolic
he performs a pit maneuver and flips her
vehicle over and crashes it and then he
walks over and she's like
help and he's like pulling her out of
the overturned vehicle
as she yeah yeah you're not even i
wouldn't
i wouldn't even describe it like that
it's it's
he so she clearly
slow like she speed i would say she's
speeding right because i watch the whole
video i mean she definitely looks like
she's speeding um i can't see any of the
other cars on the road so you don't know
if she's like going up much faster than
everybody else she's clearly going too
fast for conditions um so he goes
deplore puts the blinkers on so
but then there's no like shoulder right
there's no safe spot for her to get off
so she puts her turn signal on as if
she's looking for an exit but no exit
appears so she slows down and there's a
very noticeable change in her rate of
speed at this point in the video
um and she puts her emergency emergency
lights on right like hey i understand
like she's clearly signaling to the
officer that you know i acknowledge that
you were behind me that you have your
lights on
and
she's like
just looking for somewhere to do that
safely um which you would think and
he decides to write this up as if she's
fleeing and says like hey i've got a
fleeing suspect i'm within my rights
here i'm going to execute a pit maneuver
so for people who don't know pit
maneuver is when
you you use that again as i was talking
about that weight in that imbalance that
exists in all cars that you know except
for the you can still do it but the ones
that don't have um some cars have the
engine in in the rear some volkswagens
used to have that tesla's yeah tesla's
right um yeah you wouldn't be able to do
it so yeah another another reason having
elon musk on
and
so you you use that weight of your
engine block to
essentially smack the back of the of
another car and have it spin out of
control now the in the proper setting
the car is just supposed to spin around
so that you don't so that it can't
travel forward and then it stops the
vehicle stops forward progress what
happens here is he attempts a pit
maneuver while the car is already close
to the shoulder right so i that's one of
those like a derek chovin thing or like
is that how they teach you to do right a
pit maneuver because
where's the car going to spin it's
obviously going to smack into the
shoulder which it does then crosses the
lanes hits the other shoulder head on
the car flips it's an suv flips over
it's already a lot of weight imbalance
issues and inherent suvs uh i used to
drive an h2 for this this pro this radio
station i worked for and it was like the
worst possible thing to ever drive in
right that can imagine any conditions
and this thing is like wobbling all over
like you never get the death traps
absolutely death traps um but hey
billboard on wheels right and
so he gets out of the car and he's like
strolling up to this thing where
you know
and it's one of those look i you know i
i don't know what he was thinking i
don't want to describe intention based
off of video but looks bad looks looks
really bad looks really bad that he does
not seem
he does not seem very you know uh
worried that you know he's just flipped
a car over and potentially somebody
could be injured dead or anything and
in i'm certainly i'm sure this will come
up in the case but he also doesn't seem
to perceive a threat because he doesn't
and i go back and watch the video he
doesn't appear to have his gun drawn and
he's you know he's not thinking like oh
this is some hardened criminal that you
know i have to be worried about so his
gun's not drawn he's not approaching uh
stealthily or anything like that he's
just sort of
like it's the weirdest thing he's just
walking so he's in shock like he thinks
he killed somebody no he seems like
indifferent i yeah i would i don't even
see that and again you know that's
that's me looking at a couple seconds of
video i can't i can't tell i'm not going
to try to mind read it it looks like
that's fair the cop was in the right
lane and she had to exit so she sped up
to pass him to get into the right lane
to exit rather than slow down to get
behind him to exit like that's an
awkward situation where you need to exit
and someone's on your right and you
gotta either i don't think there's an
exit at all in the video i don't think
there's any exit that comes up like
there's nowhere for her to go basically
yeah
and right and slowly those ones where
it's like
at that point but if that were me um and
i know that there's a cop behind me with
his lights on i would just pull it over
in the shoulder if i really if i really
couldn't find anywhere cause i know that
you know other cars are going to see
that and i'm not getting out of my car
anyway so if he like really wants me to
pull over and there legitimately isn't
anywhere to go i would just pull a wrist
shoulder yeah yeah thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time